Welcome to another Stories From The
Stores
I'm here with Ben Russell, curator of mechanical engineering
and we've got the credo of Joseph Clement, so Ben what's a credo?
What's a credo, good
question. Well it's a statement of intent
What this thing does, this little
tiny notebook, it establishes a
moral compass as a young man starting
out in the world.
Okay so question number two, who was Joseph Clement?
He's a young guy, so when he writes this it was about 1790, it's dated 1793.
So he's about 14 and he eventually becomes one of the
most incredible engineers in London during the 19th century.
Okay and the big thing he made was the analytical engine?
So what Clement does is he builds for Babbage the Difference Engine
which is still in the museum's collection and they are the most astonishing precision machines
no one else could have done it probably except Clement and those he worked with.
So this is near the Industrial Revolution?
Yeah so he's up in Cumbria and it's a very
isolated place and he said I'm going to
go to London because that's where it's
all happening at this time
there's a chance he actually might have taken the book with him.
So he's up there and he is starting to write this sort of stuff, practising his signature
practicing handwriting, doing little sketches and messing around.
What does he want to do with his life?
And there's a wonderful little quote which I marked in here
'the acquisition of knowledge is one
of the most venerable occupations of youth'
and what he is saying is go
out there and hoover up information and
you are going to take it in and it will come out in other ways
and he goes out there and he
trains himself up, he's self-taught
and he ends up as one of the most
significant machine builders in London.
Is it worth someone today writing a
credo?
I think it probably is. Because it was very clear... what he's doing here is
setting out the foundations for what he
wants to do next.
Are there any quotes in there that sum up Joseph Clement as a man?
'We are dazzled with the ostentation, the
pleasure of learning and the noise of victories'
and actually for all his modesty he was a very victorious man in terms of his career,
he did some wonderful wonderful things in a subdued sort of way.